è la a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video ma lo sapevate che
c'è gomorra tuna utili comunque non è un
placement comparsa la pubblicità come le
ultime volte siamo finiti in situazioni
spiacevoli nei confronti di altre
persone visto che si chiamano tutti fa
vigenza cacchio di gioco mi chiamo poi
c'è quello vero non rompete vediamo se
qualcuno prova in qualche modo a
mettervi i bastoni tra le ruote o
fingersi me vai sofi fammi vedere come i
disegni orlando ronaldo mandarino mela
apro zucca marchio zucca proprio lui a
noi deviata su cui sono stato molto
bravo ragazzi adesso gioco sono the wine
ma come pesca ma cosa a parlare ha visto
la pesca si quadrifoglio ma che bravo
non è vero trifoglio ma che bravo avevo
messo un foglio in più
complimenti ne era professor talmente
complicata non so come abbiate fatto
indovinare difficile round 3 ko perché
non vinco perché siamo l'ultimo round
almeno posso scalare un po la classifica
e per darmi avanti più possibile carte
carta a carta signora l'attenzione
proprio lui una sola bellissima al cuore
di cuori mi mancava perché non mi fai un
picche di picche a carta per ora lo ha
giocate tutte per primo è quindi potrei
quasi vita bossolo alzabandiera che non
posso disegnarlo oppure fragola facciamo
paragonava tipo lorenzo è veramente e
poi complicata indovinare questi è
proprio complicata da indovinare
penso che nessuno forse come peperone
sono quarto nonostante abbiano iniziato
la partita 6 ore fa non regga non ho
capito che se sto schifo a miele e bravi
che la vedi dominato prima di me avete
fatto indovinare miele d'asta cagata qua
questo è un pantalone no punto
esclamativo ex la mafia microfono
no no no già scritto avrà indovinato
subito non son riuscito a scrivere con
lo scritto macro phone o micro fred
maledizione
lo avevo indovinato subito semplice
mettiamo messo una ipo perso questa
partita non me lo merito
mannaggia andiamo alla prossima dykstra
appendi a appendiabiti il camion è
facilissimo stato indovinato io che non
ero in partita ancora o un appendiabiti
o è un cielo con un collo veramente
storto ma ha dovuto detto l'asso round
basta che chi vuoi che sia il documento
filippa margherita margherita no casello
no comunque i cubi grigi sono sempre la
partenza bordone la cartella meno male
mica perché stavo scrivendo cartella
l'indovinata non potete disegnare una
cartella tipo quella che ti metti
semplicemente nelle spalle perché poi
secondo me in base alle in base alle
regioni cambia sta roba per nei ragazzi
lo zaino e anche la cartella questo per
me è una cartella cioè non so voi e la
cartella spotify come sportivo rai ma
com'è possibile allora il tecnico può
tifa ok allora devo farlo giallo ma devo
farlo perde così guarda che bel cerchio
dai si vede che spotify è veramente
fatto bene spotify devo anche fare il
contorno nero è un po sbordato eccolo
dai pirla è un'app ok apposta stati
molto bravi e nessuno si sta fingendo
mento dovesse mai fanny fa vedere se sei
veramente divertente o se sei solo
divertente di nome che cacchio è mike ma
luigi ho detto prima io verde con la l
luigi non può essere nient'altro a lui
uscito luigi come parola madonna però è
riuscito hermenegildo sonora un casinò
ha vestito non ha vestito vestito
proprio lui va indovina subito
ragazzata dai sì facciamo i seri
by sofia per tutti sofia si chiama il
suo gioco tutte sofia incredibile se
vogliamo anche io sofia vai sofia
pomodoro peperone spider man ma come ci
attaccate lo spider man una cosa per gli
ho azzeccato spider man
da questo ma poi scusa ma perché sei
partita facendo uno stick men
fai la ragnatela 1 so 1 che sparano a
ryan dunn devi farlo rosso per forza fa
uno che sbagliano le spara una ragnatela
però fa niente che cacchio è una tomba
cos'è sta roba è un a è un sandalo
sandali indovinato brava figli poi ha
indovinato brava firma parco lemonia era
difficilissimo c'è questo è un piede
ragazzi questa non è una zampa storpia
di un dinosauro è un piede fa vigente e
quello vero e per certo che dovrebbe
cioè si è scritto fa vj quello vero non
rompete sarò quello vero per forza
philip ball ma cosa mi chiedi a fare vai
filippa kamoun pillola pillolo tic tac
il mio cane che abbaia non solo sentire
che mi sta suggerendo la parole tra noi
c'è nocciolina poké ball che cacchio è a
bonn no bamba cartella valutazione
ma quello nero non so i loro bruttissimo
boomerang chi non ha vinto boomerang
l'ammazzo in giro guarda vengo lì
filippa vengo lì ecco magari ci hanno
anche ragione se lo faccio così da
cagnola non so come farlo dai ragazzi ci
ha fatto da dio
dovevo solo mandare a casa con amazon
c'è porco demonio che noi da un
boomerang cribbio ma cosa doveva essere
un mera anga quello boomerang ha
sostenuto questi cosa hanno scritto pur
no fermi lì per fermi fermi do leggerlo
boomerang boomerang boomerang un gamer
gang dart polo gang boomerang boomerang
boomerang a parigi non ci credo che sei
tu e tu non sei una pippa giraffa con
tre teste cerbero tutto qui co demonio
basta che mi sto allenando per un gioco
per bambini dove rivedere le mie
priorità nella vita
pantalone non sigaretta no cos'è
accendi spada laser spada coltello ora
che sto riprendendo pipe e fanny e
secondo me adesso l'ho ripreso non
vorrei una cagata assieme al round 3 di
tre mi sono rifatto tutta la classifica
e forse ho ripreso fanny forse non è
detto si pippa sto recando a como giardo
ma a sword brava esatto veri ecco bravo
apposta ragazzi datemi più credito basta
mattone martone mattonella un sono
secondo per un niente ragazzi io vedo
assolutamente farla giusta che cacchio è
sport e colore svenuta tastiera del suo
the rinvenuto e sta cancellando non ha
idea di cosa sia non ho idea di cosa sia
ragazzi no ha indovinato fanny l'app
orari prima doveva essere se io ho
scritto prima quando c'era coltello
invece era adesso sigaretta ma cobain
vabbè ragazzi niente sono una pippa
proprio video vi sia piaciuto gli
schietti hacker a rischio del tasto mi
piace e noi ci rivediamo ad un prossimo
video come sempre bella ragazza
[Musica]